Look right into the cameras at the thing to do or what could you or get me.
Yeah.
Great.
Hmm.
Okay, today is March 7th, 2017, and we were with Stephen Strauss who's a distinguished professor
of Forests Technology at OSU.
And we will talk to him a fair amount about his career and his time at OSU.
I'd like to begin by building more of a biographical sketch of your life and ask you,
where were you born?
I was born in Brooklyn, New York.
Is that where you grew up?
I was there until I was 16.
I left for college at that point and never went back.
Really?
I went to various schools and places of employment, but not back there since I started college.
Tell me about the Brooklyn Abuse childhood.
Well, you know, I had a very simple upbringing.
You know, my parents did not have a lot of money.
And they also, as a fourth child.
And at the time they got to me, they were sort of done being a careful caretaker.
So I really had my one of the streets, as it were, I traveled around New York City
on the subways and buses extensively.
And pretty much called the shots came to one as I wanted.
So I was a bit of a feral kid.
So that was fun.
Tell me a bit about your parents and your family.
Yeah, my father was a postal worker, second half of his life,
and worked evenings and enjoyed his job.
A great deal and had a great network of friends.
And I think he enjoyed being there, then more than enjoyed being home with the kids and with my mom.
My mom was a hard worker, but she was set up overwhelmed, I think, by the depression and raising two kids.
And was sort of mentally run out, let's say, with the time she got to me.
So, you know, very humble, simple upbringing.
You know, my parents had good values and still didn't meet, you know, ten times over the value of getting an education
and making yourself better and helped me all along the way once they realized I had good academic potential.
They kept finding money that I didn't think they had to keep my academic career going.
So solid upbringing, but also not a great deal of mentoring, advice, and you know, any of the things that I hope I've given to my kids,
having a better situation.
Can you tell me a bit more about community life and the specific neighborhood that you were in?
What neighborhood was that?
It was a neighborhood called Barrow Park in New York.
It was split roughly 50-50 between quite religious Jews, many of them, chasic, and you know, dressed in all the garb and refusing to associate really with what you might call mainstream society.
And then Italians, and many of those were Sicilians who were first or one and a half generations off the boat.
And they were rough and tough and tumble and hated Jews as much as the Jews hated them.
And I grew up with most of my friends who I had a secular type of life, my parents were Jewish, but very reformed.
Nothing like the Chacetic Jews, but I was something of an in-betweener where I played with these kids.
I was out in the street playing stick ball and football and, you know, just with Italian friends who didn't know what to make of me.
Because they were taught to hate Jews and I was a Jew, but not really a Jew because I wasn't like those guys.
And so it was a strange upbringing in that regard.
But some of these Italian friends are still very close to me, even at the stage of my life.
And so it was, you know, as they were struggling with, many of them were getting brutalized at home.
I mean, that was normal for this Sicilian culture that came from.
They came in five minutes late and they were getting beaten.
And I had a very different kind of upbringing.
So it was quite amazing to see that, see the Cittab Jews, see my in-betweener kind of growing up and figuring it out from there.
What were you interested in as you were before growing up?
Well, you know, I was interested in sports. I was just a very active sporty kid.
I still run. I referee soccer. I still, you know, I follow some of the OSU teams.
I was still a sporty guy. So these Italians were very athletic.
And so that was a real connection.
And then probably the big change was, you know, it was a gut to teenage years.
And I started, I met friends who were somewhat politically active in protesting being on board.
Being interested in recreational marijuana and things that were very common in the generation back then.
I really, I moved away from these Italian kids and moved further away after my bar mitzvah.
I did get that done because I felt like the family needed me to do that.
And then I moved away from Judaism, moved away from these Italian more rough elements and found a group of friends that were more intelligent.
They were a mix of Jews and Gentiles, but more, you would say, progressive or left leaning.
And grew my hair along. I had beads in junior high school. I remember that started and became, you know, fairly politically active,
went to a bunch of demonstrations as a high schooler and then into college.
At what point did science became, kind of something was important to you?
Yeah, you know, I had, I went to a high school in Brooklyn called Brooklyn Tech.
So New York City, there's three selective public high schools.
Brooklyn Tech is one of the three where there's an entrance exam.
And it was, it's really a place for training engineers.
And in the old school engineers were people who just shut up and calculated.
And the teaching of science was rough. I mean, for people who were gifted and mathematics, I guess it was okay.
But I was completely turned off to science. I wanted no part of it.
All the teachers, the whole education system was the opposite of my somewhat progressive interests.
So when I, so I graduated, I did take the engineering classes I had to at Brooklyn Tech and did fine.
And then when I got to college, I went to the State University of New York and purchased, which was sort of an alternative arm of the State University system in New York.
And then I did now grades at all kinds of experimental teaching systems, I'm Asian philosophy for a year, or just trying to figure out what I was interested in and so forth.
And really, because I was interested in the environment and with the State of the world.
And I didn't see how a degree in philosophy was going to really help me do that.
And I was concerned about my economic disability to survive.
And I switched to biology at that point, interested in the environment and some kind of a job.
And then I got into the science track. I was also, I had skipped a grade in middle school, junior high school, as we called it.
I was born at the end of the year. So I was almost two years immature compared to a lot of my peers.
And I was really confused in college. So I was going through these transitions, philosophy, environment, science, and just.
And using a lot of marijuana and other things. And I was just, so finally I said, time out, I took a year off.
And that was a really smart thing to do. And worked, saved money, did some great travel and went to Alaska, and with friends and other things.
And then when I went back, I was able to transfer to Cornell and become a serious science student in Cornell. Very, very rigorous.
And so really from then till now, I've just been busted in my ass, if you will.
Trying to keep up with the incredible pace and demands of being a scientist.
That's interesting. I was going to ask about how a kid from Brooklyn becomes somebody who spends his career in the forest.
And it sounds like it immerse out of this political impulse.
Political impulse. And along with that, I began to backpacks some with some friends.
I didn't know anything about the fires. I remember being very curious. What's this tree? Who knows? What does it do?
And so I got curious about it. I love the outdoors. There was an element of use of drugs in there that made me sort of worship in a religious sense.
I had some experience with friends that were just, you know, I still think of this day, these friends of ours.
Friends of mine, you know, talk about how magical it was to sort of see the environment, love the environment, be out there, bond.
Try to understand it, try to think about being a caretaker of the environment.
And so it was inspirational, is what it was. You know, all that infusion of the youth and the feeling of the need to save the environment.
And then with sort of recreational uses and drugs in the comradeship, I just became passionate about it.
So it's, I don't want to overemphasize a drug part that accepted it, gave a great sense of joy and sort of sharing that, you know, what happened anyway, but maybe it was more intense.
How did you select Cornell or did Cornell select you?
Well, I selected Cornell, you know, with my limited knowledge base growing up in Brooklyn and my parents, you know, working class, and the other one of them had a college education.
You know, we always assume the next thing you do is go to Brooklyn College or some very affordable nearby place because you couldn't possibly afford to go to town school at a long Cornell.
And my sister was sort of five years ahead of me and she set up a broken, the thinking shackles that, you know, we could do better, that we could reach higher.
And she encouraged me to apply and one thing nice about Cornell is very selective, but there's also, it's a hybrid really, between a state-supported university and a private university.
And biology is actually split. I think it still is there.
So if you get into biology and you're a resident of the state of New York, your tuition is about half.
So I made it suddenly affordable whereas it wouldn't have been otherwise.
And then I started getting a bunch of scholarships because I really worked hard and got very good grades.
And then like I said, and when my father realized I was getting a A's at Cornell, who was this kid?
He started just paying off debts and stuff.
It sounds like this was an important moment in your life, Cornell.
Yeah, it was the start of a whole new person that wasn't this kid in Brooklyn, but was someone who was going somewhere.
And I started working with an ecologist at Cornell.
It's also taking all these courses in biology and evolution that blow your mind and suddenly you're thinking about all this big, big stuff and also thinking about saving the world.
And I still never saw myself as a professor or a scientist. I just really unable to do that.
But I get a degree and then I think, well, a great, I have a bachelor's now.
What do I do with it? In the world of biology, you are a technician for somebody.
And then you think, well, I get a master's and it's really the same thing.
And so it really be a scientist to be somebody who calls the shots, who's thoughts and intellect and ideas or what drives.
What happens? You need to, in science, you need to move on and get a PhD and even beyond.
You need to get a postdoc. So I just never got off the train because I realized I needed to stay on it.
Though I never imagined myself being a scientist with my humble upbringing.
So it just kept going. I kept having success. And then from Cornell, I got into the Yale School of Forestry and Environment, which is another not today.
It's much more a breeding ground for environmental activists and policy people.
So it's fully transition. And then I went to Cal Berkeley after that, which is similar.
And so I kept getting into these very challenging, very great academic environments that were even more and more environmentally, as well as scientifically, in a players on the world scene.
How did you arrive at Forest Sciences? Something you wanted to focus on from biology, I'm guessing biology is sort of an entry to you developing a scientific foundation.
But then you focused your perspective a little bit from there.
Yeah, that's a really interesting question. I think it was the fusion of backpacking and being out in the environment.
I also remember when I was, I think, 17, I hitchhiked out from the East Coast to the West Coast.
And I was in Oregon just as a long-haired kid by myself. And I remember getting a ride with a logger.
I was up in the Oregon Cascade somewhere near Salem. Not really knowing what I was doing. This was in May.
And I thought I was going to back that to the Pacific Crest for start-back packing it. It was all under snow.
And I just didn't know what I was doing. But I had this conversation with this logger. And I sort of told them about all the things I read from the Sierra Club that helped bad,
far far as she was in the Northwest, and how a clear cut is a sin that should never happen. And he just said, now some, let me tell you what we do it.
Let me tell you what the safe guards are. And I had no idea how one-sided and biased a perspective I was getting from the Sierra Club.
And that issue actually continues to this day as I worked in biotechnology where you have organizations that I trusted as being truthful until I'm telling the whole story.
I'm not even realize, do not. And so that's one of the steps in my evolution from Save the World, simple scientists, I'll save the world.
So the real politics and real information society we're in, of course, which has exploded of light with all the fake news and everything.
But that's been going on forever to one degree or another, just not a presidential level, quite so blatantly. But anyway, that really opened my eyes. It got me interested. So what is really happening in forestry?
And why do you clear a cut? And we can be doing it safely. And can you use intensive technologies of all sorts, conscientiously and responsibly amidst all the noise.
And so that's a place that I've continued to work in for 30 years at OSU in the biotech controversy area, related to true use in agriculture in general.
Back to Yale, OK, Fest, and I was surprised to find out that they had a forest science program.
Yeah, yeah. Most people don't know about it. Yeah.
Tell me about that environment for you.
Yeah, you know, Yale was a, I went there, I first, because when I was a Cornell and I was interning to undergraduate research with an ecologist, and he was grooming me to go work with his PhD supervisor, brilliant man named Herb Mormon, an ecosystem biologist.
And I was all set to go there. And then my graduation was in the later year, because I overlooked a requirement in my advisor. And so I had once a one more year to kind of figure out who I was.
And I took a class in forestry and I just got a little more interested in sort of application and the near term sense. And so when I got to Yale to work to be an ecosystem ecologist and a trained work with Herb, and I did work with Herb Mormon son.
But I sort of veer off and became more of a physiologist practitioner as compared to an ecosystem ecologist.
But I also discovered that Yale was a place where the number of sort of scientists, particularly the number of practitioner type scientists is very small.
I mean, it had really transitioned 60s and 70s into a training ground for environmental activists, environmental lawyers.
You know, a lot of people who have populated a lot of international organizations come through places like Yale and Duke, forestry is done a similar thing.
And Cal, Berkeley, Forestry is done a similar thing. We're really to survive and be a college in those institutions that are not land grants.
Or if they are there, you know, they're mostly not, I mean, in Berkeley's case, they're kind of a split one. They really had to become really working on big issues of environmental science and a global sense. So they transitioned.
And there's still some science there in all these places, but it's relatively small or it's highly environmental.
And so it's, you know, in Oregon State still we have, we have a lot of that too, but we also have a much bigger because we serve, we're in this region with this incredible forestry sector,
whereas New Haven is not in such a region anymore. There's still a little bit of forestry, but very, very little by comparison.
And so we here try to serve both, you know, training students to work in the industry, work in the land management agencies very actively,
as well as do science and be in the cutting edge of the environmental issues. So anyway, but being at Yale was very much a step into that world, which is a world I wanted to be in my whole life.
But I also realized that I was a little naive maybe in thinking that science had more of the answers. And in reality, I found that science has a lot of answers, but mostly the laws and social perceptions make it difficult to have those answers sort of be used, particularly in genetics, which, you know, we can talk about at some point.
Yeah. What was your research focus at that point?
Yeah. So at Yale, I did two or three projects there were also Yale doesn't have a master's thesis requirement. So I got involved in research projects. I went out to the US Forest Service in California in Berkeley, actually, where they had the Pacific Southwest Station, their work with scientists there.
And got my first paper was on the inheritance. So pines have these turquinoids that make them smell sony and the resin that comes down and tries to protect them from bark beetles and so forth. Well, the chemistry of that resin varies widely.
And so sometimes you have one chemical, sometimes another, and it's important to the ecology and the organism. So I figured out how it's inherited some scientists before me, Bill Critchfield, a very, very great man, had made these hybrids between different species.
And the progeny then had high alpha pining, low alpha pining, and we're seeing all these chemicals. So he said, did this basic meaning work, crossing species with different chemistries, and then you could map the genes in the progeny.
So he basically said, here's the progeny, you want to map the genes. And so I went out and measured them, you know, with help of the scientists, and that was my first paper.
And then there are a couple of other small projects like that. So really what it was very much being on the premise and sciences like that a lot where you know people do projects over many years, and then students and postdocs come in and sort of figure it out at value to it, tweak it, and particularly with trees, but you know, science in general, or you know experiments take years to decades.
And so I came to the stream of science that the farest science, the farest service scientists were doing in Berkeley, and was able to publish in papers. And that set a set me up for, you know, getting into grad school in Cal and success from there on.
Was that your first exposure to the treated ethics? I mean, it's obviously.
Yeah, really. And I went to Yale, it was not, I told you it was the D.D. ecosystem scientist, and I started working for a geneticist there that put me on a couple of projects.
And then he set up this opportunity with a far service in Berkeley, California, named Tom Lettig. He passed away from cancer a couple of years ago, but very, very, very well known internationally.
And so he, and he was at Yale, and then he moved to the farest service. And so they set up those opportunities. So I went to Yale, you know, no particular interest in the United States. I was open to it. And then the opportunities, the people.
And then I went to Berkeley too, you know, that was partly to work with Tom Lettig, but I still was open to being a physiologist, a silviculturist, managing forests in a larger scale, maybe an ecologist, even of some kind.
And then again, opportunities, the farest service there. Also one other theme in all this is one thing that's frustrating me about ecology, and it still does a lot is it's hard to measure things precisely.
You know, it's, it's, and to somebody a lot of scientists, they want to get to the bottom of things. They don't want to have a conclusion that says, well, maybe this can do that, maybe this. We have data, we have models, you know, works this way. And that's just a nature of the beast.
And in genetics, you tend to get much closer to hard answers. And that was, that was appealing to me. And then all the genetic technology that was coming along continues to just, you know, my whole career, the field of genetics is exploded five times, was attractive.
You know, first it was enzymes and first was turquinoids and the chemistry thereof and the gas chromatographs. And that was these enzymes you were doing to look at genetic variation in a way that we never did. And then it was DNA and then it was genomics. So doing DNA on massive scale. And then genetic engineering. So it's been this progression of incredibly powerful and intellectually exciting and potentially very important technologies.
So that's also pulled me out of ecology. These technologies and I've been using ecology quite a lot, but it's taken a long time to get there. Sounds like it was a fairly seamless transition to Berkeley for you.
Well, yeah, you know, I've been there before and, you know, I knew the place and I loved it. You know, I just loved being in Berkeley. Those five years I was there. It was, you know, it's a great environment for a young person.
It's definitely a very artificial environment. And the reason I say that as I one of my memories from there is I think the first year we were there, this would be 1980. I hope I have the story right.
Reagan was running against, I think it was Jimmy Carter, maybe for Carter's second term or something like that. And even being Berkeley and think that Carter was a shoe in.
And of course, I think you won no state but Massachusetts or something like that. And, you know, so again, you're in this little bubble of Berkeley and you know, everything's very progressive. You know, realize where the country's at.
And so we said it's our little bit this last election. Yeah. Tell me a bit more about this time. I progress through your PhD years. Yeah, the PhD in Berkeley was really a good for me. I really enjoyed Cal Berkeley a lot.
It had a lot of sort of what I was mentioning about. Yeah, the environmental stuff, the foam and the science. And also out a lot, still a lot of the traditional stuff, some of the older economists and
and so-called, it's very, very famous people, Hank Fox, John Zavnuska, my main mentor at Berkeley, Bill Libby, very charismatic guy, very much really in the mold that I've taken on a mic, or I've kind of been a spokesperson, if you will, for the use of genetic engineering as a technology in forestry.
Which is a difficult thing. And it's difficult, biologically, it's difficult socially. A lot of the incredible power of environmental groups around the world that's exploded during my life.
They're almost all opposed to either unilateral or extremely negative. So Bill was kind of, he was a proponent of cloning in forestry. So, you know, you got to a wild forest now. Every tree is a unique genotype.
Like humans mostly are with the exception of the occasional identical twin. And he said, well, what if you could pick the very most productive one out of this mass of variation, you know, not just one, but the top 10, the top 100 for production purposes.
For wild forest, you'll maintain all the diversity you possibly can, but for production forests, if we could clone it, the benefits would be you, clone them, the benefits would be you.
And so he argued that his whole career and had some success. I mean, some of it was used, but he was very much pushing against the tide at that point. The industry was very traditional.
And then the environmental tide as well. So I've said in a sense, following in its footsteps, which is interesting, you know, being a good biologist, I think, but being also outspoken on some of these policy issues and using sort of innovative, new, socially novel genetic technology.
And me and the GMO area and then the the cloning area. So anyway, you know, he is a very outspoken guy and so he is very influential to me.
And but the whole intellectual environment of Berkeley was very stimulating. I T8 and forest policy. So, you know, as a young scientist, I would say, have a limited notion of how policies are made and how laws are passed and what they mean.
They just figure, you know, you learn how it works in nature and then you do it smarter and better. And the notion that there's all these layers of rules and regs and perceptions, invested interests, you know, we're just kind of naive.
It's just that simple. And so being at Berkeley was a time where I really sort of got my eyes opened up, you know, taking and teaching about forest policy, just, you know, realize that, you know, scientists really want to change the world.
They really need to be out there. They can't be naive in their labs and their little fields. I have to be out there interacting with society.
And, you know, I think I've done some of that, not as much as some of my colleagues, but, you know, and I think today you see a lot of activity on campuses and that scientists need to do even more.
I mean, I have this March on Science, March 4 science coming up in April and I think it's science to say, you know, it's just not going to be okay to be quiet. You have to get out there.
And speaking for science is also, I'm rambling around a bit, but speaking for science is also really complicated. The scientists are all biased and ideological, like everybody else. So it's a really messy thing.
Your dissertation was on Stolagenetic Science, that correct?
It was, yeah, it was back in those days. They had these enzyme technologies called ice enzymes or alazzynes. So it turns out that, you know, you have thousands of proteins in your body, trees due to, and due to genetic variation, the forms of those proteins vary.
They just do what they do, but they do it a little bit differently. And so back in the 60s, 70s, 80s scientists realized that instead of measuring genetic variation, see based on variation and height of people like ourselves that are influenced by the environment, how you have will you eat, as well as your DNA, you could look right at the products of DNA and these proteins.
They weren't able to look at DNA itself yet. So that whole alazzyne genetic diversity technology was very, very big for 30 years.
And that's my thesis is about trying to see if you can look at the amount of genetic polymorphism, variability in these enzymes, and trees, and could you predict their productivity?
Are trees that have a greater diversity of enzymes, are they more productive and natural environment, using the materials that are available to me. That was the question that I tried to answer.
And I had some success in the sense that I got some publications out about it in good journals, but by no means that I resolve it at that level.
Now that question, actually, a bigger question in science still continues.
So you finished up at Cal in 1985 and then you arrived at OSU, how did that come about?
That was an amazing thing. So I did this thesis that was really about genetic polymorphism, whether it predicts productivity and environmental stress tolerance, was another element of it.
And it had experimental plantations, but it wasn't really about production, it wasn't about biotechnology. By any means that wasn't called biotechnology, we didn't have that word really back then.
And back at the time in the 80s when I was at Cal, the field of biotechnology came to be called biotechnology.
So what we're combating DNA, cutting and splicing genes, was starting.
It started in bacteria a few years earlier and scientists were beginning to use its study diseases, the study cancer, to study human pathogens of various sorts.
And then it started percolating into plants where people were using it the same way.
And then scientists figured out how they could transfer genes from one organism to another.
So they could do, say there was what people have done in bacteria years earlier, they could now do an implant so the possibility of genetic engineering plants for enhanced traits suddenly was there.
And everybody was talking about it.
I remember I think it was 84 years before I graduated. My mentor Tom Lettingley, I mentioned from Yale, it went to Berkeley, held a big conference about how should we be using biotechnologies in forestry.
What are the opportunities, what are the constraints? And I'm watching this and I'm not a biotechnologist. I didn't really know what DNA was per se, apart from, and suddenly it's like this is the next big thing.
It's coming at us. And then the year 84, 85, depending on exactly how you dated, the first genetic engineer plant was created.
And then two years later, the first genetic engineer tree up off our tree that I've actually continued to work on mostly.
And my career was created. And the forest service was working on it just seemed like this is just a big, a big wonderful thing.
It was a big scientific technological challenge. And so I remember when this job came open at Oregon State, I was somewhere around December or so of 84, maybe January of 85.
And I remember seeing it, someone pointed out to me, so we've always had Oregon State. We've always had really strong forest genetics.
It was a sub-discipline of forest science. And we've been strong in, at OSU, we've been strong in the forest service right across the parking lot.
And so we had a geneticist, Kim Chang, who was retiring. And so they said, well, what should we do? Should we hire another Kim Chang? Kim worked on psychology, meaning chromosome level, genetic biology of trees, Douglas Farr.
Or should we start going down deeper? Just go down to the DNA level. That's where the science is going on. It's all this foaming going on.
And so we said, we're going to take a risk and hire a biotechnologist. And I don't think any other forestry school had done so yet.
But at that time, there were two or three that did it. So I don't remember if it was us, or if you see Stater, who was actually number one, but we were right there instead of taking this risk really to invest in this new area.
And so at that point, there were not a cadre of forest biotechnology, PhDs, and postdocs around. Because the field didn't exist.
There were a couple just starting who had done work and other species, barley, a colleague of mine, Dave Neal, and I know what you grabbed, very great scientists, had done a postdoc and barley learning some of that stuff.
And so I was intrigued that these were some of my competitors and for this job. Anyway, so I asked my mentors, I just said, you know, what's with this biotechnology thing? Is this like flash in the pan?
Should I apply for this job? I don't have backness. Yeah, you should apply for it.
Yours qualified as anybody getting how young this field is. And then I went on this crash course of learning about biotechnology. And so I applied and they basically hired me on the notion that I had potential to grow with the field.
And I would say, I just think that turned out to be a pretty good guess. And so that's how it started. I really, this is really a new venture for me. It was a new venture for Forestry and OSU. And it's had a number of turns that no one predicted.
But it's from a science point of view from a career, a development point of view, it's been very successful.
Yeah, sounds like a nice piece of strategic thinking or visionary thinking. I think so. Yeah, I think they knew they were doing that. They didn't really know where it was going to go. And I got here, you know, I said, so what do you want me to do? I said, I don't know.
Well, what's biotechnology figured out and do it and actually the first five, seven years. I realized that genetic engineering was not really, you know, it had been done once in one place. A tree was engineered, but it wasn't ready to go.
So what can I do and what I realized I could do? And I was also very successful and made a name for myself early was I could use these DNA techniques to figure out the evolution of some of our major tree species.
I think I had the most important paper at that time on pines and how they evolved. I had the most important paper at that time on Douglas Ferret and it's relatives and where it came from.
And relationship to all its relatives around the Pacific, where I'm in the on. So there's a lot of insights that you know when you get to the DNA level.
The when you get an insight about relationships and evolution, they're often very, very strong. This is this thing, this precision. You get when you sequence or analyze DNA to that level suddenly people say, well, it's not just his opinion about whether the size of the cones or the thickness of the barks and most important trade.
It's this sort of random look at the DNA and it just shouts at you which trees are most related to which and who the common ancestor is.
And so what I did the first five or seven years, I did a lot of this genetic evolutionary analysis.
I did some really high quality science and the people at OSU even though my dean department had what a love to see me like help the forest industry right then and then I said, this is the right thing to be doing right now.
And so it was, you know, they did have a very open mind about it.
But then eventually and perhaps I'm getting ahead of myself, but I'll mention briefly what happened in Oregon and in Northwest is people started worrying about sources of wood and pulp.
Because we had the spotted alowars, we had rising environmentalism and people were afraid there wouldn't be enough wood.
So they started investing the Department of Energy made major investments in growing these popular trees and plantations like the ones along I-84 that we talked about.
Now those are products of that and so people started doing series research and that there's a big project at University of Washington on that.
And I realized that I had the expertise that was developed to add a genetic engineering element to it.
And that started early 90s, late 80s, early 90s.
And I started working with the industries and developed an industry cooperative consortium basically a public private partnership and our college of forestry has a bunch of those and still does where they provide money.
Not a lot of money but enough to sort of help guide it toward things of interest to them.
And then we at the University said use our resources and go out and go grant dollars to sort of make good science of relevance happen.
And working in poplars, I mentioned the first tree that was engineered was a popular.
Suddenly people are thinking about growing poplars on a major scale in Oregon and in the Northwest.
Let's use this technology to do it even better.
And so a lot of my career has been said if I took that step for this consortium, started working in poplars and genetic engineering.
And I quickly got involved also in some of the social and legal issues of it.
Like I said earlier, those are big and they continue to be big.
So that was the reason I made that shift early in my career at OSU into the genetic engineering per se and also helping to deal with the social elements, working with industries, forest industries, biotech industries.
And so that's been kind of the big middle of my career and still continues.
What is it about poplars that make most attractive to this work?
You know they're much better from a science point of view, they're much better model organisms.
So everything about Douglas Fur and Pine you can imagine when it comes to doing genetic manipulation is hard.
I was terpenized I mentioned early, well they mess up your getting your DNA out of analyzing it.
People have sort of got it got over it these days but it's just one other thing.
The genomes are huge.
In poplars we figured out pretty early on.
In fact the number one tree, how to insert a gene or modify a gene and then grow the progeny and see how that one gene affects them.
And in the conifer that's still incredibly difficult to do, very expensive and very difficult.
So something about them makes them easier to engineer.
They're genomes are small, they grow faster.
It's very powerful in genetics when you make a genetic change or you have a genetic variant of interest to make copies of it.
Just for replication so you have high quality science, poplars in nature, clone themselves all the time.
That's you know these astins you may have read about these grows of astins.
There are kinds of poplars can cover many many acres in one single genotype.
That doesn't happen much in conifers.
So they're easy to make copies of.
So there's a bunch of reasons easy to transform small genome, easy to make copies of faster growing.
That make them very good genetic models.
And then also you know the industry was already looking at making hybrids between different species to increase productivity.
They were already cloning them for plantations.
And so the genetics was very intense.
And then adding genetic engineering as another kind of genetics made sense because you'd already...
The industry had already brought it in science, has already brought it to this level.
Let's take that level further.
When you look at Douglas Ferrer or Arkindz, even today, the genetics is primitive.
You know compared to any crop species compared to poplars.
And so it's much harder to say genetic engineering is what we need to do now.
We're still sort of in the neolithic with breeding.
So it doesn't make as much sense.
The accomplish it does.
So you have all these reasons, the biology as well as the state of breeding.
And then also if you're making a particular product with poplars like pulp or particular kinds of wood or biofuels,
you can optimize it much more.
And that's how the industry came about, whereas in this sort of generalized forestry,
we're making all kinds of things under all kinds of conditions.
We don't control the environment as much as grown on it.
You know, steep hillsides and poppers, it's more agricultural.
In fact, they're regulated as agricultural crops by Oregon and Washington.
And so everything about the social and biological environment made it sensible to consider trying to add in genetic engineering as an ex genetic technology.
Yeah.
Backing up just a hair, I'm interested in collecting a little bit of institutional knowledge about the university and of the college.
What do you remember about your early impressions of OSU and of the college of forestry?
You know, the things that stand out over all these years, Dean Stoltenberg, who hired me,
and successor George Brown, just this incredible sense of, you know,
out there and making impact.
Serve the state, serve the nation, serve just this incredible ethic of service.
You know, I came in here still, somewhat young, still very much wanting to do science.
And wanting to survive also in academia, I was very nervous.
And I'm not going to be able to get tenure.
And they really wanted much more.
They weren't interested so much in making us survive and get my name grand.
But what am I going to do to change the world for the better?
Well, how am I going to, and also they had a sense of how am I going to serve the Oregon industry better and make Oregon more productive and economically more vital.
So I just felt that and I felt the pressure of it.
But I also felt that it was wholesome and real and good.
And so that was another reason for the transition to poplars.
I mentioned I did this genetic work early on on the evolutionary relationships at different species.
That was a great way to use biotech methods to advance science.
But it wasn't really going to advance Oregon far sure.
Right? And except in a very fundamental level.
And so when poplars came along, and in fact, I could use genetic engineering.
I could do great science.
And it can have an impact on the industry and on society maybe tomorrow.
If we can really grow trees, you know, 10, 20% better by using genetic engineering methods.
And we can do it in poplars in my lab and get it out there.
You know, that's exciting.
That conjunction of application.
And you know, one thing that we've worked on too for many years that tied into my environmental background is, you know, it was pretty obvious to me that
genetic engineering trees, poplars, we're going to be controversial for variety of reasons.
We've already seen it in agriculture and medicine.
And so it's not like society is going to just say, rar, rar, rar, let's have more of it.
They're going to say, I don't like this, or they're going to say, who controls it?
And so on and so forth.
And how should we regulate it? What's the role of the EPA being?
Should we really have very strict regulations?
So, you know, it was obvious to me that was all going to happen.
And what's happening and the biggest issue that science can deal with about that is, so release of propagules into natural environments.
So I think cognitively you cross a line when you say we're going to genetic engineering or something.
Then you're really saying that humans are really taking control of this organism and changing it to their needs.
Of course, we do that with conventional breeding, all of our crops, corn, whatever it is,
are looking at nothing like their wild relatives.
And we've made that cognitive leap.
But I think now we're even more conscious of that than we used to be.
The genetic engineering, because it's an unnatural, mostly unnatural technique.
It does happen in nature, but not commonly.
You cross this cognitive line where it was obvious to me that people are not going to, well, people might say,
well, except in these intensive popular plantations that look nothing like a natural, that genetic engineering can have a place,
but I don't want the pollen and seeds spreading out into wild riparian cottonwood areas,
where really what we value is biodiversity and all the ecosystem functions, that's going to be a problem.
And indeed it is.
So we said, you know, so we need to, for those plantation trees, we need to shut down flowering.
We need to treat grow faster as a result.
But the main thing is that even though poppers do vegetative, we spread a little bit, we can manage that.
But we can't manage pollen floating miles and miles in there.
And so another exciting thing was in addition to developing the gene transfer methods and working with industries to test things,
we said we're going to develop the genetic containment technology, so society accepts it.
And we continue to make that our focus all these years, and that really tied into my sort of environmental consciousness coming in.
Let's use advanced technology, but let's do it right.
And so that's probably what I'm most known for around the world is developing this containment technology and putting it into practice.
It takes a long time.
You know, the science takes a while, getting the genes in, and then if you're studying flowering, you have to wait years, because trees don't flower right away.
So what really is, I didn't realize there's so much at the time when I made that decision in the early 90s, I was committing to two or three decades of experiments, and that's what's happened.
You know, they're still going on, they're still on the field outside for a while.
At what point did you start to receive some pushback from various outside entities? Was that pretty much from the get-go?
You know, in the beginning, there really has been, and I don't know if anybody's measured it, I'm sure I should have said that, so they haven't measured it.
I should probably go find the papers, if they've done it.
But I used to mock some of the media coverage, and including OSU's own public relations, that here's biotechnology, it's to answer to all our problems.
It's going to feed the world, it's going to revolutionize, we're going to make square trees, that just go right into the boards, all this crazy stuff that I knew was not going to happen, and I'm not going to happen in my lifetime.
So it was heightened.
And society, that's where they were sort of giddy about it.
I think it was the late 90s when various things happened in agricultural biotechnology, where then the media coverage became pretty negative, and big environmental groups like Greenpeace, with hundreds of millions of dollars of funds, essentially environmental corporations, decided they were against all of it everywhere,
whether you were making, you know, a fight in the need to deal with blindness, whether you're trying to make tree, or against all of it, it was an ideological thing.
And so, probably because organizations like that, with a lot of power and money changed, things shifted, things became much more negative.
And then, again, in the later 90s, when you started to see a lot of vandalism, first in agricultural biotechnology, then in forestry.
And so, in 2001, was a big year here at Oregon State in Corvallis, we had vandalism, somebody came in during the middle of the night, you know, in Corvallis, and cut through a wire fence and damage to about a thousand trees.
It was at night, and you can't tell the ones that engineering, engineering for ones that aren't, so most of them, they actually didn't get what they wanted to.
You know, it was indication of just the intensity of the issue that I think was in March, and then in June, there was arson against the collaborative of mine at the University of Washington, and his building was almost completely burned down.
A collaborating industry in Klatsk and I had a million dollars in farm equipment damage, so it really ramped up, and it really got intense.
I was the chair of an international society for tree biotechnology, and we were having a meeting in Oxford in, I guess it was 1999, a couple of years earlier, and the one field trial of the engineering tree in England was vandalized the evening of our international scientific conference.
And so all these things, you know, told me that holy cow society is not with us. And then in Europe in particular, which was sort of violently reacting against Lonsanto, and bringing in, you know, you know, Genevieve engineering soybeans as animal feed into the country and blockating them and all that.
When these trees were damaged outside of Oxford, these trees were trees that had, without going into the technical details, they were engineered to be easier to pulp, meaning take less energy, less chemicals to produce the same amount of pulp.
So it's something that we have thought of scientists, the environmentalists were in love, and that we have strong support for it, but no, the bigger narrative in society really dominated that.
So when these trees were destroyed, the science about we were doing was irrelevant, and the story line in the major media, the Guardian and others was Monsanto now, you know, they're wreak havoc and the food supply, now they're going to wreak havoc and are forests.
So we were all like holy cow, you know, what are these guys smoking? But you know, that's how big then the social narrative is about genetic engineering and GMOs.
The details of the science really don't matter much, and that's a hard thing to remember. But anyway, so, you know, 1999, 2001, also in 2001, we had 9-11 in the United States, and the government called eco-terrorist terrorist.
They pursued them the same way as they pursued people who are bombing the World Trade Center. And so that kind of stuff stopped.
The guys who did the stuff in Oregon and Washington were mostly cotton, but in jail. And Europe continued in the US, it stopped.
But that was, you know, a big marker that things were just crazy at a hand.
The site is actually continued to ramp up after that. And, you know, one of the conditions we have today is that green piece and others who are very against this stuff have created conditions where forest industries really can't use genetic engineering.
Period. Their own certification organizations don't allow it, even in research. So the field trials, the collaborative work I dealt with industry years ago, doesn't happen anymore.
Because, or happens outside of the Northwest in very special conditions, because the social conditions have become so hostile.
You know, just like you, just like in organic food, you can't have any GMO in it no matter what.
Even though scientists will say, well, there's good uses of it. In addition to the ones that are questionable, it's an all or nothing thing.
And that's where society is at with forestry uses right now. And one of the things I've done in my career is try to argue that we need research to find out what are the good ones.
And we find out what are the good uses, what are the not so good uses, how we can make a not so good use and make it good.
And, you know, that kind of, that's really not gone anywhere, even though I've tried to sort of what I would consider to have a more middle of the road, more reasonable science based agenda, the environmental community, the marketing,
and the environment in particular feels like this is the way they have to be to get the consumers to buy their products, to charge more for it, and maybe do the right thing on their view.
So, it's become a hostile world. I'm really, I'll be able to finish my career using this technology, but by and large, in forestry around the world, the amount of interest in genetic engineering as I'm death that has really gone.
It's not zero, but it's really gone way down. The social pushback has been big enough anybody could have imagined.
So, how have you been able to navigate that or how have you, have, I'm forced to adapt or compromise?
Yeah, you know, it's a reality, and you know, it's important to recognize it's sort of a 12 steps thing, recognize what you can change and what you can't.
And so, you know, I've written a bunch of papers about how a smarter way would be to regulate what a smarter way to be, to market it.
I had a paper in Science Magazine last year. I've been able to publish in the very best journals, putting forward ideas of collaborative with lawyers and economists, to get the social stuff right, being a biologist.
But, you know, there's a larger, larger forces, larger social economic forces. You know, big companies profit from, you know, avoiding GMOs. They're not going to stop doing it.
You know, it's not just philosophical, it's a huge profit margin to saying you're cleaner than now. I call it greenwashing, but it's everywhere in the marketplace.
Now, I can't, I can't buy a loaf of bread that I want without a no GMO seal, even though I'd like to avoid it because I know it's meaningless.
So, that's, you know, it's a bigger thing. So, what are you doing that, man? It's from my point of view. You know, we had at OSU, we had an outreach and biotechnology program, mainly funded to the College of Ag, probably funded through Forestry, that I was the chair of the director for about eight years.
It was kind of a soft program. It used to be something that was a hard program, an extension, and instead of got softer over the years.
But, we did, we had a, we had a website and we hosted 40 public lectures. We got amazing scientists, moral law, the common and popular public in Corralis about all these issues.
So, that was one way that I thought I could sort of really help change society or make society smarter about this.
And I think it was super successful. But, I think OSU, the College of Agriculture, has sort of tired over this and there's only so much science can do.
And so, they've sort of backed away. They don't want to alienate their more organic elements, they're not an GMO.
And so, most universities, not all of them, but some large majority have said, this is bigger than we can deal with.
Our state funds are being cut. We'd rather have somebody who's breeding berries than nobody breeding berries and have somebody fighting this wave of anti-biotechnology.
Because it's very complicated. It is. If you do a responsible outreach about it, it's not just RRRR. It's here's the trade-offs.
There's a pros in the cons and the center. So, it's a complicated story. So, anyway, from my own point of view, I've sort of fought road scientific papers, talked to regulators.
I still give 304 or 5 talks a year about, I talked at the public library in Salem to the environmental educators consortium up there a few weeks ago.
So, I still do things occasionally. But, the basic I've said, you know, I could do research to advance the science and the technology.
And when society is ready, if they're ever ready, it'll be there. And so, that's where I put 95% of my energies is doing the science.
And it's hard. One thing, the conditions are sufficiently adverse in both Europe and the United States for applied biotechnology in the public sector.
That's very hard to go to a USDA or department of energy grant power and say, I have an idea for a better genetic engineer treat.
We're going to tweak this and that. And then they're going to say, well, it's a GMO, right? So, it's going to be really hard to get regulatory approval.
Companies are going to have trouble growing it. So, we're not going to fund that. And that's happened the last 15 years. It's very hard.
But the one kind of funding that you can still get a little bit of is if you want to say, well, we need better safety technology.
We need to not worry so much about getting better trees, but getting safer trees. And so, that's really that.
Middle niche has allowed me to say that continue doing the research I do on genetic containment and so forth.
And so, that's one of the ways I've been able to keep doing what I believe is interesting and important.
Getting the science done, testing it in the field, to me, it's very important. Not just that I do laboratory work, because you need to go out into a real, real world.
Most laboratory ideas don't actually work because the world is complicated. And so, I have stuff out. I have 10 acres growing in Carvalis now that are testing ideas from the field, from the laboratory.
At any rate, but it's this safety orientation that's allowed me to keep productive, keep doing good science, even though the social milieu is extremely adverse and funding is very hard to get.
So, the work on bioseafety and sterile nursery plants has almost been a survival strategy in your point.
Exactly. Yeah. And it's survival, but it's also something I said I'm interested in. And when I started that construction, started working on poppers, I said, we need to figure out containment.
And so, I'm still doing that. And luckily, that hasn't dried up. You know, it could anytime, but it hasn't so far. And I do work that is state of the art.
It's competitive throughout science and throughout agriculture. So, these are the panel that funds this. It's mainly a USDA panel called biotechnology risk assessment that won the ARS thing that you just mentioned was a separate thing related to it.
But that's funding all of agriculture. So, we have to be doing work on trees that is competitive with the very best work in corn. And that's hard because they have a lot more money in there, a lot more advanced genetics.
But I'm proud that I've been able to do that. I can compete with those guys. Because the science we do is just as good. If I didn't dug the store, I probably couldn't. But I can do it in public.
Something else for you that caught my eye was the project on carbon sequestration using copper trees. Yeah, about that.
Yeah. Well, you know, it's interesting. If you decide you're going to grow trees seriously for some purpose, meaning they're going to have a dominant dedicated use.
What nature gives you is okay. And you can tweak it further. But often you want something very different. And so, people do ecological modeling.
Started saying, well, you know, if we produce trees that had more roots and less stem, which is contrary to what people do in forestry. They tend to want the fastest growing tallest tree.
I said, no, maybe we don't want the tallest one. Maybe we want the fastest one with lots of roots. And the roots will add to the carbon and the soil and decay much slower than stem material.
Maybe maybe we can even make the roots so they decay more slowly and hence the amount of of turpinoids and phenolics, these compounds that slow down decomposition so the carbon stays around in the soil longer.
Because those ideas that we could change the allocation between tops and bottoms and change the chemistry of roots that would promote carbon sequestration, that was the idea.
We also thought if we had a tree that has more roots, it'll survive great stresses. It'll bioremediate soils better.
We also have a problem in industry that sometimes we can select the fastest growing trees and this has happened in the Northwest with Poplar as they blow down.
We get these giant windstorms every now and then and they just blow over. And so, and then also we have an agriculture of the green revolution, which is not a biotech GMO thing, but it's a bunch of technologies starting in about the 1960s.
The key one is a scientist figured out that we don't want taller wheat, we don't want taller rice, when you just select for productivity, everything gets taller.
And then when you have a storm, they blow over, they lodge. And you probably see this around Pendleton that happens occasionally.
And then the crop is lost, the roots, the qualities goes. So what the scientists did is they found a dwarfism gene, semi dwarfism, that keeps the wheat instead of being in a way over your head and keeps it about here.
And mostly we see around our areas like that. But that's a particular gene brought in from an Asian variety that constrains you from getting tall.
So it gets more root, so it gets more seeds on it, and it doesn't launch. So it was also that thinking that maybe we can sequester more carbon, have a tree that's more drought taller and bioremediates better by having them be shorter.
And I'm not talking about three feet tall, this is a tree. So instead of 100 feet, you might be 60 feet. Whatever, between slow it down and change the distribution and the quality of the biomass.
And so that's what that project was about. Trying to tweak these trees for these particular goals. And we were successful at it.
We did, you know, and some of the genes we tested were genes from the green revolution wheat. And because the mechanisms are very fundamental, they work quite well.
And so we were able to get shorter trees with more roots. And, but was anybody going to use them? No, because they're a GMO and because they're, it would change the industry.
Industry doesn't work that way. Breeding would have to be radically different. We'd have to get a GMO probably into the breeding program.
Because one of the things you're doing is you're creating trees that are smaller, grows fast, while the nature, those trees die, right, because they can't get light.
So you'd have to change the whole way you breed trees and evaluate them. And anyway, it would be very disruptive to the industry.
But with the GMO element, it was a non-starter. So we did the work. It was successful. And, you know, there it is. The science is done. Does somebody ever want to pick it up? I don't know.
But that's what that was about in short of it. Yeah.
And that was a project that had an association with SunGran, is that correct? That's right. Yeah. That was a Department of Energy USDA funded. There was a couple of them.
The biggest funding we got was from the biofuels section of the Department of Energy. That was a big, and then we had some supplementary funding from other places.
We've also got funding from the SunGran and a couple other places on trying to make a tree that would have some valuable coal products.
So one of the problems with growing bioenergy is that energy is cheap in the world.
Unless we tax fossil fuels really aggressively, which were not almost anywhere. As aggressively as it probably should be, they're not competitive.
So how do you make them more competitive? One of the ways is to engineer in some product that is high value, a new biochemical that would be have some other higher use in industry.
So we've tried to get trees that produce bioplastics, things that you can use. And we're already using the similar versions from bacteria, these cups that decompose, that you can put in the compost.
We tried to make the same kind of thing in popular trees. But we couldn't make enough to make it economic.
So we really need a major engineering leap to make that work. And so we're just no funding for it. But it's also a hard problem.
But that's what one of the SunGran projects was about was trying to figure out how to make those biofuels.
We collaborated with companies that were doing in a different crops. And it's a hard problem.
I thought a student who's sort of working on an element of it, but it would require a pretty serious effort.
Has any of your work intersected with the cross-laminated products at all?
Only that the short answers know. I was at a conference, the PENCO Foundation, is this Forestry Foundation funded by this.
I assume which guy who really wants to infuse advanced engineering technology of all kinds to make better wood products, including the laminated products for Oregon and for the industry.
Why aren't we doing genetic engineering? He's looking at all the amazing things in engineering in the traditional sense.
Why not genetic engineering? And I went to this conference with other engineers. And I told them, it's the broader social element.
And it's also that the industry is not ready for it because we're still sort of in the neolithic breeding wise.
And so it would just be like trying to teach a baby to run before it's able to walk, just didn't make sense.
He didn't want to hear that, but that's the reality of it.
So it could be done. But before we did that, for example, if you're going to have the precision of genetic engineering to try to get the fibers to be bonded in a way that would be better for CLT or glue better, whatever it might be.
The first thing you want to do is just homogenize the wood. So as an engineer, you want to know what's going to be a certain thing.
And then you can tweak it right. And right now, in our forest, the variability in wood properties is incredible.
So you first want to be able to probably clone trees.
And the problem with that is that it's not affordable in the industry right now.
So unless you get to that, that's again, you know, crawl walk before you run.
We're not going to get there. So I also told him that the industry until we can get to those barriers, they're not ready for it.
And that's no matter of economics and probably also social acceptability.
Would it be okay to have clone Douglass fur all over the landscape?
I don't know. What does the Sierra Club say? They probably hate the idea.
So, you know, so industry, but due to economics plus concern, it's just not happening.
Tell me about the Leopold Leadership Program. I'm like, God, that was something really important to you.
Yeah, that really is a, that's a great thing. And it, you know, resonates today.
So Jane Lumpchenko, an OSU, a standalone professor, you know, president of Triple White House, National Academy member, you know, amazing scientist and person.
She and some colleagues said, you know, scientists don't have the skills and the network to communicate with the media and decision makers like they need to.
You know, her interest was in getting more environmental science and science in general into policy.
You know, and most politicians don't have science backgrounds, almost none of them do.
And so you need to talk their language. You need to know, you know, how they, how decisions are made.
You need to know how to talk to the media, you know, how to talk to science journalists, non science journalists.
So, they she created this program. It was funded by various foundations over the years.
It's still centered at Stanford, an organization at Stanford, still goes on.
And they train cohorts of something like 20 or so leading environmental scientists.
People sort of in a mid career who you can see have been very successful and are going to make an impact.
And our, our, our, our called to, to speak to the world, to change the world.
Very much like who I was growing up and who I still am.
And so you apply, you say what you do, you look at your publication record, your passions, your skills.
And so I was one, I think I may be the only person who would call himself a biotechnologist in that program.
It's mostly ecologists.
Two lawyers involved, double economists. But pretty much very strongly environmental people.
People not so much working on the, the technology side of it.
But anyway, this, this group has been going on now. I'm going to guess 20 years, something like that.
Well, they have these cohorts of scientists who come through and a lot of them are now, you know, very well established in the field.
And there's a network of them and they communicate and they collaborate.
And they try to organize action or let us to the editor and conferences.
So particularly now in, you know, with all the things going on in the job administration, it's kind of been, you know, come back to life.
And where they're really trying to do things and so forth.
And so anyway, that's, I'm part of that organization.
And you know, I love to see information that share about how to be more effective.
What do you do now as a scientist? What's the right thing to do?
There's a discussion going on about whether it's good or bad to engage in the March for science next month.
Is that politicizing science more?
Making us more of a special interest group versus, you know, arbitrage of truth?
Or not? Or we have to.
And so that's an example of how that network helps.
People think distributed information and so it's very nice.
You know, like I said, I'm kind of an outsider in it.
And I kind of feel like when it comes to GMO, those in biotechnology and agriculture, probably the majority of them are negative on it.
You know, and I'm kind of a lone wolf there and saying, this is powerful. We just have to use it right.
So, you know, so I'm involved in that and it's important to me.
But it's also a network of environmental scientists that are mostly not interested in the kind of stuff that I do.
But anyway, there it is. I'm not super active in a bi-need means probably because as I said, it doesn't.
It's kind of a little bit to the left, whatever it is of where I'm at in terms of using technology in the world.
Can you talk a bit more about GMOs with respect to food? That's obviously a big issue for people.
Yeah, you know, I followed that pretty intensive teacher batter at OSU. I've been doing that. I had this outreach program.
It's very hot and very political and, you know, I think one thing that's really clear is that it's mostly not about the science.
I think the people who are very against GMOs want to make it about very dangerous and adequately studied science.
And I just think for them, that's a tool of tactic. I think the people in the know no better than that.
So, but there's issues of intensive, probably the biggest issue is industrial agriculture in general.
It's incredible benefits and incredible harms. Probably plowing is the most damaging thing we do the whole planet.
But it's not just industrial agriculture that plows. It's organic agriculture and everybody else. And they often do it more.
And then you have use of agricultural chemicals, which are an incredible energy saver and productivity enhancer.
But they can be used with they can harm things. You know, the Rachel Carson and Silent Spring helped show that for DDT.
And so now we're in a whole different era than we were back then where things are intensively regulated and monitored.
And many bad things have been taken off markets and you know, at least in the western world.
And to get a chemical approved, you know, takes I think hundreds of millions of dollars of tests and studies and the labels that are restricted to use and so forth.
So there's a lot of safeguards built into the system we didn't have back in the old days. But it isn't good enough.
Now it's not going to be perfect. We're going to make mistakes.
So how do you think about chemicals used in agriculture? And you have systems like the organic certification system that say it won't use any except actually for quite a long list of exceptions if you read the details.
But so that's another element and the major GMR crops now use chemicals directly and directly.
They use chemicals in the form of promoting herbicides by being herbicide resistant.
They use chemicals in the sense of isolating a pesticide from a bacterium and putting it into plants.
And this pesticide is something called BT is one that's widely used in organic agriculture. So it's very, very, very safe.
And they've spliced it into a plant. Well now it's supposed to be very unsafe.
So you know there's all of it anyway, but it involves things like chemicals and it involves intensive EPA regulation.
And the more you regulate doesn't mean that people feel better about it. It means it actually shines a big spotlight on it.
And so it's just extremely messy both from a society and so on.
And of course the science continues to grow and innovate. So there's new stuff all the time.
So how much regulation just impedes public benefits in peeds economic development versus protects the public and the environment.
And getting that right is crucial. And you know I by no means a supporter of the current presidential administration in the particular individual.
But the issue of how much regulation is too much is a really hard technical one.
And the sound bites you get in all the news media are generally misleading and wrong.
But in the area of biotech and I've written a lot I think the regulations are totally out of control.
There are some kinds of biotech that should be intensively regulated probably more than we have now.
And other kinds really there's this good record that there's no regulation needed at all.
Zero. We have this single gene editing.
The new technology from modifying the natural DNA there to for strenu reason which is what breeding does.
But now we do it with science and precision.
That's probably going to be regulated certainly in Europe like it's taking the gene from a far away species.
It's from my clinic just crazy.
Is this the CRISPR technique?
Yeah, that's the CRISPR technique. But that's kind of and you know that's a big source of controversy right now.
The USDA pedal to proposal to not regulate some parts of that which I think is you know innovative and forward looking.
I don't know what's going to happen under the current administration.
In Europe it's very likely to go that way either way the organic people are going to have already said I'm record they they will not accept it.
So you know it's just an ugly messy area frankly.
And it's right was traded off so I just gave a talk last night to my own laboratory group.
There was a very good paper lately on the record of GMO crops in terms of pesticide use.
To use more to use less these better kinds of chemicals.
And the reality is it's a mixed bag.
We're doing all that depending on the crop and the timeframe and and it's just that's the reality of it.
But we know there's also billions of benefits to the economy because it's also improved soil as a result.
So what's the right answer?
So if you like sort of simple answers this is not the area for you.
So that's you know that's so that's sort of I tried to when I speak about impeach about it.
I try to give students a sense of both the frustration and anger at this simple minded social response no GMO labels.
Organic certification you know I'm cleaner and better than you.
And the big reason of that people go to organic now so I GMOs regulations are so intense that breeders like me.
I could be breeding populace for Oregon using GMO techniques except that it cost me 100 million dollars to release one variety.
Even if with with CRISPR it's just like on the other hand you know we have companies over using herbicides and creating herbicide resistant weeds.
So it's it's just really complicated and difficult you know so my own personal point of view is don't throw out the baby with a bath water.
You know take some intelligent mill ground but that's not where society's at in terms of marketing and labels.
That's not where regulations tend to be that the regulations reflect people's fears.
So regulators like to say they're science based.
No where are they really science based they try.
They're always trying but the political pressure is incredible.
In the US and in Europe to actually make a science based decision and the activist groups work so hard to influence the science to get their people on the boards and to change the way decisions are made.
So again you know I was so I used to be a member of Greenpeace and they are a club and friends of the earth and all these guys and I now I wouldn't give them a dollar.
So you know that's where I started right and now I don't trust them.
I give a lot of money to certain environmental organizations like the Nature Conservancy that are really science based but these guys are not.
So who's the good guys anymore.
So anyway in the whole food GMO food biotechnology or you get all that.
The good guys the bad guys the bad guys are the good guys.
How do you decide?
Yeah I have a note here to ask you about the future of forests.
Yeah right.
Yeah a big question but yeah and here you talk it feels to me like a lot of what you're doing now you're creating work that might be used in the future in a different environment.
Yeah and I think that's right is it fair to assume you think that the future forests might on some all depend upon genetic engineering?
Well you know I've made the argument one thing you have in the world with climate change with people traveling around the world with pests evolving ever more fast.
The stresses on forests are enormous.
There is you know various papers recording you know hundreds of introduced and new pests that are damaging forests everywhere.
It's an incredible difficult thing.
And you know the main way we deal with that is through bio control conventional breeding but sometimes those don't work.
And so one case you may know the story of the American chestnut I don't know if you're familiar with that.
It's a species that was a dominant species much like Douglas Fur around here all over the East Coast entirely destroyed by an exotic fungus.
And so that was a hundred years ago and now people have been working through conventional breeding and bio control to the story and so far not much left.
And so a scientist in a state of University of New York has found he studied the mechanism of disease.
The pathogenesis how it really works and it's like other pathogens where he's found that they produce this thing called a xalic acid that actually is what kills the tissues that produces a xalic acid.
It kills the tissues and the fungus acts as kind of a saprified and just basically eats the dead tissue.
And he said well if we can just get rid of their xalic acid or turn it way down maybe we'll turn it from a pathogen into a saprified.
It'll still be around but talking really damaged trees. So he did he's done that kind of amazing thing. He took a gene from wheat.
In fact put it into chestnut and he's appeared to be resistant.
So there's a case where genetic engineering was important and it was able to very very quickly do what breeding other techniques couldn't do.
And so that's kind of a well known case but then we have lots of other species that are sort of an earlier stages of that same devastation.
There's an emerald ash borer, there's hemlocked delgit, a few other things around the world that are in that category what looks really bad for the species.
So from my point of view when you have a crisis like that you want to use all your tools.
And genetic engineering is definitely one where you come in you don't say well what genetic variation the tree species has is going to have to be good enough.
You say what are all the tools I have and if a guy stayed in University of New York or elsewhere says I think I understand how this pathogen works.
Let's take a gene and move it let's tweak a native gene maybe we have we do have some things that are somewhat similar in chestnut but we need to edit it.
We need to do crisper to change it.
And let's do it fast because this is an emergency to get this out and start testing it right we can't wait for 20 years of regulatory analysis and ecological approval.
But we can't do that. Can't do that today because of the rules and the regulations and people's phobias and the inability of companies to see that they could ever use such a trait.
So there's almost no investment in that kind of technology.
And to me that makes no sense. That's just that's just you know when you're you know the line between precaution and paranoia.
Procution is sort of you know taking intelligent measures to you know look before you leave.
Power and oil is being so afraid and building an institutional system that's based on fear.
And that's I think that's where our app with genetic engineering and it makes no sense.
So you know anyway so I think it could be a powerful technology for the future.
All trees could be semi-dwarf in a future time if people were to actually allow that to happen.
And maybe they'd be more productive and more stress resistant but we're not going to know in my lifetime if that's true or not.
So you know I you know so I think this powerful things we could do that I think the uses would be selective.
These really more egregious cases that I mentioned because conventional breeding is very powerful.
And there's essentially no limits on it. You could take a species from anywhere in the world and move it here to Oregon and if it works you know it's fine.
So that's radical genetic engineering really.
And we can do that without any constraints but if you tweak a gene there's these huge constraints and issues.
So why mess with tweaking genes when you can do that other stuff.
So you know we sort of paint it ourselves into this corner if you want to you know a bit.
Graduate students assume come to your lab because they're attracted by your work and want to pursue similar topics.
What do you tell them? I mean it it sounds to me like you hit a time period of cultural history I suppose where you can work that you did.
Right. But that window is closed.
Well I tell them you know I tell them if you think you're going to graduate and get a job in the forest industry doing biotechnology the job opportunities are extremely small.
So I tell them you have to be competitive with any agricultural biotechnologist you need to be able to get a job one of those companies or the USDA that's still doing some of this particularly for serious diseases.
And you need to have what I call bioinformatics training.
Meaning that you know putting the GMO thing aside you need to be able to do state of the computational biology which doesn't involve GMOs because that's the entree to where most jobs are.
And the broad area of biotech science. So you know otherwise a lot of them come to me because they're motivated by the things we're talking about.
They want to see the world changed because they see how powerful genetic engineering is.
They see all of this information out there including from the good guys and they're angry and they're passionate.
So you know I tell them you know I always write open this is the reality.
So that's what they say but again it's really critical they do state of the artwork. It just happens to be on trees and then they're going to postdoc and they'll be able to move into other areas.
A couple of concluding questions that I'm interested in your perspective on change in the college of forestry that changes very visible to everybody right now is it's a big homework.
Yeah but tell me how the college has changed and moved in different directions and years of your association.
Yeah you know I think we have a great leader and you know Dean Thomas Matt is very visionary who really wants to move the college ahead very powerfully he wants to sort of move into the environmental mainstream if he can.
He's trying to build much better bridges with environmental organizations than we've had historically he wants to reduce the polarization we've had amongst the more in pro industry and the pro environment folks and I think that's happening over time successfully.
He wants to move into the advanced you know laminated technologies and this new building that's you know a big part of the money and the push is to do that kind of thing.
I think that's really positive colleges also now in different parts of campus and that's heard sort of a sense of unity that we have.
So you know I think I think he's trying to set us on the right path and do the right thing and I hope he can bring his vision through the completion but I think that's a set of unknown right now.
What kind of impact do you think the new forestry complex might have on the college?
Well you know I think new buildings I've been discussing this with various colleagues you know it's obviously a big cost.
But you know the environment you live and work in matters it matters to how you feel how you interact with people.
I'm in Richardson Hall which was about 15 or 19 years old but it was designed with lots of light lots of wood and it's brought people together.
It's been even though it had its own little design flaws we found out keeping out things like rain.
You know it's a really beautiful environment and so I think he wants to take that to another level and create really a sense of greenness and collaboration and you know an innovation that I think a new building helps to motivate.
So you know I like the idea and I think there was criticism about whether it was green enough and how green you need to be to tear down existing functional building but also quite old fashion and not a great collaborative space at all.
Very much in the old model people basically infile cabinets.
So you know I think they're not a lot to try to be green while also making it something you can sell to donors.
Because donors don't want to invest in you know changing the sighting and existing building if they want to invest in a vision.
And so I think you didn't really have the choice but to create a new building.
So I'm hoping that you know that the dean comes back and the building is as beautiful and as functional as you hope it will be and helps you know bring us to another level.
So but right now I think we're in this kind of precarious place where a year or two out I'm happy in that building.
And all building projects I know of it cost more than you think and then you have to make difficult decisions as you go and does it actually do everything you thought you were going to do with it.
I think there's those risks as well but I'm hoping.
Yeah.
And my last question a few.
This is a sesquicentennial project and I'm interested in your point of view on the university as it looks towards its 150th birthday.
What do you think OSU is positioned right now?
Yeah I really felt really fortunate to be part of this institution for the 30th and going on my 30th first year that I've been here.
I've felt the leadership that I've had in the college of far she's been excellent.
John Barr and Ed Ray I think have been you know inspiring and responsible leaders.
I have not gotten involved in administration significantly so like every other faculty member I know of I wonder if we are investing far too much given our limited state budgets in administrators they just seem to be everywhere.
So I wonder whether every administrator is really needed and what they're doing what their impact is.
But in general I like the ethics and the structure of the place and I'm proud to be a part of it.
So you know I like the emphasis that we have on equity and diversity here and I think that's really important.
Oregon is a very white place and it's a white place for institutional reasons and in my opinion those need to be corrected and addressed.
So I'm proud that we're doing that pretty actively we're doing them pretty actively in forestry as well.
So I think that's the right thing to do.
So you know in general I feel good about it.
I would love to see more of the administration explaining who they are, what they do and how cost effective they are.
And they don't seem to feel they need to do it.
So I don't think that's right.
So in that regard you know I would love a little bit more of a business sense of explaining to faculty how they're making smart decisions and what the administrative decisions that they make really cost as compared to you know I don't know
could we have 10% less administration 10% or 50% more faculty members doing innovative research and teaching.
You know I just those trade-offs I don't understand them and I don't know anybody does because I don't think administrators feel the need to explain them to plebeians like me.
And I know I don't like that.
Anyway but so in general very positive but you know with some sense that maybe we have some runaway administrative investments and I think that's a common problem in higher education.
You know so as far as I understand it so how do you how do you reign that in or how do you at least understand it and decide if you agree with it or not.
Yeah certainly not the first time I've heard that.
But in short I mean I feel privileged to have been here the community has been an extraordinary place for me to live and raise my children and you know as I when I go back to my yell were unions and those folks are all over the world and they say hey you know you traveled everywhere where where where would be your ideal place to live I always say I'm living there.
I travel the world too and this is an incredible place to be.
No that's a good enough to stop on thank you very much I really appreciate this.